hey welcome to the Reuben report I'm the
guy that told Obama to use an orange
line instead of a red line dave rubin
I've got Jackie Geary and Ben mankiewicz
with me the first time ever by the way
that we've had a guest bring a computer
to the desk I'm a little nervous about
this Ben I shake things up hema yeah I
did it on I did it a match game in 1979
and jeanne was queasy it said but it
worked out well alright well we have
computers and we have plenty of
information for you we're going to start
off with Syria I thought the war was
going to start last week they've given
us a little extra time here as we know
Obama is going to Congress right now
this thing is going to happen there's
absolutely no doubt about it John Kerry
was speaking to the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee yesterday I think
it's kind of funny that we've decided
that somehow going to a group of people
whose approval rating is fifteen percent
is what's going to decide whether we're
going to war or not we are going alright
so let's start though with Nancy Pelosi
because she apparently gets her wartime
advice from her five-year-old grandson
I'll tell you this story and then I
really do have to go my five-year-old
grandson as I was leaving San Francisco
yesterday said to me me me my name Mimi
war with Syria are you yes war with
Syria no war with Syria no it's five
years old and worn same war I mean we're
not drawing that war we're talking about
an action yes for Syrian no one is here
I said well what do you think he said I
think no war I said well I generally
agree with that but you know they've
killed hundreds of children men they've
killed hundreds of children and he said
five years old were these children in
the United States and I said no but
their children wherever they are so I
don't know what news he's listening to
or higher precision but even a
five-year-old child has to you know with
the wisdom of our interests who had it
affect our interest well it affects our
interest because it was a again outside
the circle civilized behavior was
humanity drew a line decades ago that I
think if we ignore we do so to the peril
of many other people throughput cetera
okay so we all get it she's trying to be
cute there and humanized this thing
except it seems to me that her
grandchild actually has more of a sound
foreign policy than she does because her
grandson said are they American implying
if they're not American then maybe we
shouldn't do this which seems to be
something that Nancy Pelosi pretty much
believed until this war what is the
Botox going straight to her brain I
guess that's really the way to start is
essentially like me me no me me yeah the
kids are not they are not United States
citizens don't do it Mimi and she was
like oh kids isn't that funny did she
realize what the kid was saying there
cuz the guy was making the point they're
not Americans don't do don't do it the
fact that the House Democratic Leader
missed the point of a five year old
story but I've year old story was pretty
clear right no war okay I have a
follow-up question because you appear to
be pro war are the kids Americans no
they're not and then she turns that into
so I think he sees the world and how the
world works people involved rain tough
days
stop stop stop I start saying words she
then relates it back to the red line
that the world has set and I don't know
if you guys saw this but just like an
hour ago Obama speaking and now he's
saying it's not his or he never meant
red line this is the world's red line is
there anything that's true anymore you
know we had a coup in Egypt a couple
weeks ago and they refuse to call it a
coup the red line is no longer a red
line is the bigger problem here that
this is now all about words we're not
even honest with the just the way we
word we're just we're just gonna use a
lot of words and say things and try to
get out of having said things and change
what we said into something else
completely as a people we spend far too
much time worrying about the words in
the first place what matters is the
action what matters is the policy it
shouldn't matter whether Obama said the
red line of the world said the red line
or not just mean it's useless because
you say something doesn't mean you have
to do it later if I say to my girlfriend
if you ever uh you know if you ever
above if you ever sleep with somebody
else I will leave you and then it turns
up no I don't want to leave her we have
a family like like what if I if I
committed some grave horrible error
right but no I get to make my decision
then based on the circumstances on the
ground okay so what would you say they
just for the record as I know she hasn't
right that's good so she's a bit of a
[ __ ] yeah right wait wait but so for
all the people that are saying well
Obama set this red line and it's not
Obama's credibility on the line it's the
United States credibility you just don't
see that as a valid I think that for
this is a perfect example of what we
talked about far too much in the rich
world pon de tree uh-uh and in general
we talk about reputation and sort of
earning respect and doing damage to your
reputation and most of all hypocrisy
like the world is a complicated place
the Middle East is a perfect example of
that complication and yeah maybe we took
an action here we didn't take an action
air because circumstances change they
change every day and the right thing on
thursday may have been a different thing
on monday yeah does it seem to you guys
that this is really not about Syria this
is really about Iran because it seems to
me that Syria was only doing stuff in
their borders they've already killed a
hundred thousand people which is pretty
awful that it's we're building this
thing up they killed them in
in cool way I old-fashioned a
conventional that the classic way uh but
that it seems to me we were putting all
these destroyers in the Mediterranean uh
Russia's putting a bunch of straight
destroyers in the Suez Canal like this
thing is leading to that Obama really
set a red line that's important about
Iran and the nuke that this the chemical
weapons they may not be the real issue
here I got ya got it's certainly
possible i mean i think there are two
big concerns i also think that before we
dismiss using attacks on syria which I
you know would would rather we didn't
but mostly because I can't see how it no
one has yet unless you've read something
that I have not no one has made a case
as to why it will be affected other than
we have to do it if we don't do it it's
ineffective rather than here's what it's
going to do that's exactly what they
said yes but it doesn't matter that even
though hundred thousand people have been
killed uh as you say in the classic way
and Turner Classic Movies approves of
the classic yeah yeah uh as long as they
kill them in black and white and uh we
like that and they're not that much
blood when they die we can't see if the
kids dress up look at away but if the
world the world has made like these
decisions that the world makes about
things like chemical weapons that matter
it do matter and they broke that and I
unlike I don't know about you guys but
unlike Iraq I don't really have any
doubt that this that this information is
seems incredibly I'm right the great did
this so I get that you have to do that I
get the feeling that you have to do
something that there has to be action
taken and that we can't just say those
hundred thousand people were killed
conventionally you know that's bad but
we don't take action but these fourteen
hundred and four hundred children who
were killed in the chemical attack is
different it is different how you react
to it obviously is incredibly tricky so
why do we have to do it every time
that's the part you know Obama has been
this big un guy and everything has to go
through the UN but he's now the one
that's exposed the UN for the total
fraud that it is because we can't get
anything done in the UN cuz the China
and Russia so why is it the US I don't
know that we're any better than Canada
how competitor doesn't feel they have to
be we've decided were the police somehow
and we're in charge of everything and I
think that's why a lot of countries are
annoyed by us you know to use
light term is just that we feel like
this is all our business yeah um which
yes it's horrible a terrific I'd uh but
I don't see what its gonna do and nobody
is coming up with any sort of real plan
that seems it will make any difference
it's just the John Kerry threat of well
if we don't then what yeah well all
right so speaking of John Kerry so he
was speaking to the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee yesterday explaining
why we have to go to war and he made a
minor gap would you tell us whether you
believe that a prohibition for having
American boots on the ground is that's
something that the administration would
accept as part of a resolute this German
it would be preferable not to not
because the there was any intention or
any plan or any desire whatsoever to
have boots on the ground I think the
president will give you every assurance
in the world as mi as the Secretary
fencin and determined but in the event
Syria imploded residence or in the event
there was a threat of a chemical weapons
cache falling into the hands of
al-nusrah or someone else and it was
clearly in the interests of our allies
and and all of us the British the French
and others to prevent those weapons of
mass destruction falling into the hands
of the worst elements I don't want to
take off the table an option that might
or might not be available to press the
United States to secure our country so
he clearly accidentally told the truth
that is the truth they can't guarantee
if something goes down that we might
have to put troops on the ground he
later said that it was a hypothetical
question and he was thinking out loud
I'm for you know generally you should
think in your head and speak out loud
but you know he's it's a big thing there
okay so is that the next step is what
you're saying is that we start this
thing and even if it's just about
bombing some empty buildings we don't
know what's gonna happen Syria could
attack turkey they could attack Israel
then they have to respond and then yadda
yadda yadda there's a possibility that
things don't go well can you imagine
I mean make gosh I mean what do you make
been about John's about Kerry's just
complete that's a complete and utter gap
right like didn't they found it into his
head whatever you do don't say pajama
set it right at the percents a complete
another gaff but it's true so I like it
I'm glad he said it because of course
it's true it's also true if we don't Bob
yeah the fact is bombing may make the
chemical I don't know whether the
chemical weapon stash or more or less
likely to get into the hands of so we
have to consider you know as what we
didn't do Iraq very clearly and I just
got back in Telluride Film Festival and
I saw uh Errol Morris's documentary but
with Don Rumsfeld known unknown we're
really are it's either the known unknown
or the no no no no no no right but he
had and what we didn't do was look past
stage two we're like I will win ye Zi
they'll throw roses on our feet and then
we'll just get out we'll take will set
up a bunch of permanent basis will take
their oil great what could go wrong so
what would carry same could happen now
and could Syria could the wrong weapons
fall in the wrong hands or stay in Assad
has any attacks yeah that turkey or
Israel is brought in some way if
somebody else get of course that could
happen and then we're then we're gonna
put boots on the ground yeah right yeah
so all right so final thought on this do
you guys see this as inevitable as we
sit here right now are we absolutely
going to war in two weeks from now
that's all so essentially what Carrie
was saying it was so interesting it was
like well if Congress decides not to
support the president's plan then what
happens he was essentially saying well
you know that you're gonna yeah it's
gonna happen so don't Obama look like
the biggest schmuck ever if we don't go
to war because now they've laid out the
case so if Congress votes no doesn't
Obama have to do it anyway just for that
same hubris that you were making fun of
though or who does he look like a
schmuck too mm-hmm to the army guys I
think they care about what the army guys
I do but I mean so look like a schmuck I
mean look if it's wrong I don't and and
maybe not you know and and you know the
you know the soldier who chooses not to
fight is arguably the bravest soldier of
the mall to totally bastardized Bob
Dylan's line and perspectives adaptation
of it but uh so I don't know I mean look
if it's the right thing to do if you if
there's a plan that could really hurt
Assad with the 41 days of precision
bombing yeah then I don't know that it's
the worst thing in the world are I think
that you'd probably turn a lot of the
country around but nobody quite believes
that that plan is even possibly in
existence right that's the problem yeah
all right well obviously the story is
going to keep unfolding stay abreast
with Nancy Pelosi's grandson and also i
was watching CNN yesterday and Wolf
Blitzer asked one of the guests why
haven't the Americans cared about this
for two years and maybe wolf it's
because you guys have completely ignored
okay all right let's keep going with
Congress so you know Congress has been
on this five-week vacation that they
take through all of august in the first
week of September we talked about it a
couple weeks ago this was originally set
up because they didn't have air
conditioning in the buildings in DC so
it was very hot and it gave them a
chance to go home and talk to the people
and really mix it up and do town hall
meetings and catch up on summer reading
that's actually on Congress's website as
one of the things that they do don't
baby they can't real yeah Usher right so
good yeah right so as we speak right now
they're actually still on vacation so
even though this is all going on with
Congress right now Obama norvelt Boehner
Boehner I can't boner boner I'm calling
a boner for now they haven't called them
back officially even though this whole
war things going down but what I found
fascinating about this is that the
Democratic and Republican leaders they
actually hand out toolkits to the
members of Congress to go home that
instruct them on how to behave when they
go home and have to deal with their
constituents there now focusing on small
gatherings because remember a couple
years ago with Obamacare that these
talent the town halls got out of control
they were being yelled at and had to
answer questions and that's not what
they're in business for that they should
do more on Facebook and Twitter and
things like that what does it say about
our political system that the leaders of
the parties have to give out
instructions to Congress to go home to
their constituents that they can't
do it on they can't even spend five
weeks at home with their own people and
know how to act they need toolkits scary
I need a how-to guide gotta talk to
these people they want to talk to me and
interact with me it's terrifying and
they put they they are terrifying as
evidenced by 2009 yeah and all but do
you get you have to get your job talk to
the humans yeah is there anything more
terrifying than an 80 year old woman
yelling at you about in front of a group
of people and you know no actually no
yeah I I you know I I'm not gonna jump
on Congress for this as much well I'm
gonna do it equally because those people
in the who went to those earrings are
batshit crazy and like like there's a
different world out there now and it's
true of it's what my overwhelming
sympathy for Obama is my frustration
with him outweighs my sympathy with ya
for him but he's got a a party in there
and we get so wrapped up sometimes in
what he's doing and or lack of nobody's
not doing but he's got a party there
that is impossible to deal with they're
not and then there then those guys go
home and you realize partly why they're
nuts is they just get screamed at for
stuff that they can you know get
challenges birth certificate challenge
this challenge the defund you can't
defund Obamacare got past right no uh-uh
so I don't know I wouldn't want to go
home for five weeks and sit through
those they're pointless there a giant
waste of time there for show to so look
here I am mixing with people but you're
not go to diners everyday you want to
talk to voters figure out some other way
in your district to to you know go on
give you know go to the assembly line
and talk to guys as they're working on
their lunch break but these are for show
and they ended up having vitriolic angry
sometimes racist screaming at them in
some ways I felt moderately sympathetic
some of those right-wing oh yeah I mean
I totally agree especially when it was
happening a couple years ago cuz of
Obama it was crazy and it was racist and
you're right it's just a lot of people
yelling and then of course cuz the new
cycle one crazy thing gets picked up in
someone's making fun of McCain and yes
essays I okay fine um but don't you
think now with exactly what's happening
right now they are home still shouldn't
they be doing this in answering
questions about the war I mean she is
that you still think no matter what it's
just show
should be explaining themselves i mean
you know look we live at the you know we
campaign in the television age they can
reach their viewers they can reach their
voters looking twitter it's in the kit
right at 12 you know maybe the kids that
don't the kids embarrassed right but we
know but of course these guys need it i
mean some of these guys are not there
they're super dumb yeah i mean you know
we know I think I'll i think most of
Congress is pretty bright i think a lot
of them i don't even know I used to
think most a lot of them are in it for
the right reasons but a lot of them are
just you can see by talking to them
they're just dumb they don't have a
sophisticated worldview they don't think
things through so they need a kit so
they need the kid can we take away the
vacation do you think that they deserve
who else gets a five-week make a
conditioning now there's air
conditioning now I until later they have
it and if you if you're going to make it
about then it's not vacation it's about
reconnecting with the people then you do
you have to get over it and try to
reconnect with the people and you have
to move it what do we now never gonna do
it because we got scared a couple years
ago and it was scary and uncomfortable
scary and uncomfortable I would love to
see Morris all right we're doing that
again one more time um so it needs to be
and I would just love to see them maybe
they need a tool kit on how to deal with
crazy people in a strong effective way
where it is shut down because I feel
like so many of them when birthers are
these people would come at them would
get uncomfortable and not want to say no
that's insane he's not a citizen of
Kenya he does have a and and wouldn't
shut it down appropriately and so it
kept I don't know my crazy I wait listen
so is the real problem here that because
of the way the system works that we
can't really get good people to become
politicians anymore so then you get be
sort of dullards especially in Congress
and then they don't want to talk to
their people cuz they really don't know
the issues i would venture to say that
there's some crazy percentage of of
congressmen that don't even understand
the basic functions of the branches of
government or or or the names of simple
foreign leaders what a government
agencies do and there may be a
government agency but it requires that
you know and then and then you know and
alec meets every whatever the hell they
meet and they tell everybody in every
legislature had act and those guys every
one of those guys's you know eventually
that's who makes up the republican
congress and i might be this is
no great celebration of many Democrats
either but yeah you know and obviously
old when you get back to it with that
all it all comes down to getting money
out of politics and because the real
issue isn't whether they take five weeks
off to go home which is the idea in the
first place I mean that's really why
it's there's that this wouldn't be a
Congress that was there 50 weeks a year
in session in Washington the real issue
is that the the health care bill was
written by insurance companies and and
that every other bill that we have is
Rena and the banking business and the
what Wall Street wrote the banking
reform law that those are the that's
what that's why these guys don't stand
they don't have to understand it they
got they have corporate interests
writing the laws that now govern the
rest the other no he progresses turning
against Obama it's just something i'm
still largely sympathetic to my as i
said i don't know what he's supposed to
do with these guys i literally don't
know what he's supposed to do me been
unsuccessful I got that but I don't know
what he's supposed to do and that's the
irony of the situation why I started
that the idea that he's now going to
approve a war from a group that is
fifteen percent approval only in America
would that make sense even though that's
what he should do okay enough about war
and politics and Congress let's talk
about the most important thing happening
this month there's going to be a new
iphone it's coming there's actually
going to be a couple of them let's take
a look at the first one this is the
rumored gold iphone 5s it's going to be
gold people and it's on a fancy red
stand there I don't think that's gonna
come with it apple is expected to launch
two new models uh that's going to be the
5s right there it's gonna have
fingerprint technology and then they're
gonna release a cheaper version in many
many colors that's gonna have a plastic
case and then you know there's gonna be
some other fancy things series going to
be a little bit better and will get a
faster processor and all that so you
might be off of the cheaper version
series not gonna be on the cheap that's
what I read it Benson yeah she don't
come cheap that's why I I could be wrong
cuz hey I don't know what I'm talking
about the I don't care no but I have a
feeling like that might be one of the
things they take out to make it cheaper
you heard it here first people series
off the plastic one so what I want to
talk about what this is do you guys
think that Apple has started to lose its
cool factor is it starting to happen you
know when they
we were coming up and they did that 1984
commercial and they were fighting the
power and they were going to change the
system and they basically defeated pcs
and now they become such this big
monolith and Steve Jobs isn't there
anymore and it feels very corporate and
they show commercials that look them you
know that everything's so wonderful and
then it says you know designed in
cupertino but they don't show you the
sweatshop in China have they lost a
little something to you guys well the
sweatshops China or what make it so
depressing I mean it but I think that
what the sweat shopping I want them in
the commercial I think those would be
moving yeah for sure I don't know I feel
like now with the 5s it's just what we
don't know what more colors fingerprints
oh and that is exciting I do this but
what else is there you know I think
they're a little like yes are they a
little less cool because other people
caught up which was inevitable you can't
stay ahead in this there's me you know
why cuz they're smart guys everywhere
yeah and those smart guys I you know
Ivan's I see the guys with the galaxy or
whatever and it's also cool yeah yeah so
you know there are a lot of cool guys
then the first cool guy seems less cool
you know but i mean i'll get a 5s by the
way my my iphone 5 broke your iphone
yeah it's okay you just can't talk on it
okay so sorry so that's that goes to my
next point so your iphone 5 broke i have
an ipad i have a macbook air i have an
iphone blah blah blah they all have
ripped frayed cords i went into the mac
store the apple store last week and the
guy accused me of doing the the phrase
was something like you're you're abusing
this in an unnatural manner something
that yes i'm a BS I hang myself and and
you know it's like some kind of
auto-erotic I mean their stuff does fall
apart because it's being made in China
but you're gonna keep buying it you're
gonna keep buying and I'm gonna keep I
and that's to say I guess went through
three ipads from november to December I
sped eyes pad 3 3 i's pads like one
weakness nothing I would get it home and
the the charger wouldn't fit in the
thing or I would get it home and it
would just shut off autumn and I kept
having to take it back and they kept
replacing and it was like I thought this
was supposed to be where this didn't
happen it wasn't crap what I like is
that so my iphone 5 visit it just it you
can talk on it
it de frias as you touch it to your face
it starts freaking out a little dial
numbers or it'll mute like it's
impossible so I use a cord but it'll
still mute like so it's try to make a
phone call text yes I had it over a year
to make a photo on your phone that's the
first problem so I call uh I call them I
get them on the phone and I try to
explain the problem and he's like well
you gotta do a hard reset I can but I
don't I got I don't want to do a harder
sell they got stuff on there that staff
right and he's like I'll cloud I figure
ask my girlfriend to them uh and I get
everything on the cloud basically um but
then he's like have you dropped the
phone in water but no I didn't drop the
phone in water we've got to tell ya and
that and then anything oh you dropped
your phone like dude I've had a phone
for 14 months yes oh yes abrupt but like
eight times yeah drop it all the time
but everything else works like the
internet works everything else work and
the conversation themselves are so
exhausting that it rid dry it wears you
down but what I find is that I'll go to
that apple store and you got a guy who
was accusatory yeah right immediately
who said like 'hey-- you [ __ ] your phone
but you know really get it in your right
and and then but I've gone and sometimes
they're like oh that's too bad let me
get you another one yeah and I don't
know I don't know how that happens
sometimes they just give it to you well
I don't know how they do it but
interestingly what he said to me when he
was at first it didn't appear he was
gonna replace any of my cords I said
well you know I have the macbook I have
the type and the blah blah blah and he
said you know one of the things we do
here this is the manager he goes one of
the things we do here is we have to
treat everyone the same and i thought
this bumpers up that socialism but we're
but also we shouldn't have to treat
everyone the same because if I have all
your [ __ ] well that I should be treated
a little better than the guy that walked
in and bought you know or that has one
ipod from 20 years it's a thing that guy
thinks he's saying something nice but
what is essentially saying is you've
been a loyal customer and I don't give
yet he's pulling the old you know if you
bring cupcakes at your third grade
birthday party have to bring cupcakes
for everybody cuz if you bring cupcakes
for three people well then I very
quickly i go to meet my girlfriend and
baby when they came back from a trip to
the Midwest when she returned to work
just last month uh and so they're uh
coming off the plane and
they get the nanny in the baby it's like
traveling would have rolling stone and
1982 like the some girls to her and so
and I speak up to the top part not
through security but right on the other
side security just so they'll see me so
I can help get down I'm went there for
like eight minutes thousands people come
off the plane it's her plane eventually
she's gonna come off and I've been up
there and then there's no one else there
or else there and of course then not a
TSA guy but like a TSA manager comes up
to sir you gotta wait downstairs I'm
like I'm just they're coming right now I
told her I'd here uh it's my wife from
and my aunt and and baby in the nanny
and I get so much stuff and I just want
to use now if I if I let you up here I
let everybody up here and literally I'm
like there's no nope here's a you let me
up here you just let me up here that's
it that's it that's all there is uh but
I lost that fight hey because you can't
get her because the second like I went
back and forth two or three times and
then I think I'm in an airport yeah no
don't yeah you gotta you gotta go down
that's what they say you can't fight
city hall you can't fight apple and you
can't fight the TSA okay let's jump back
to politics for a second but a slightly
lighter side of politics celebrity and
politicians you know our politicians
have basically become celebrities at
this point I'm pretty sure we've already
coronated queen Hillary which is really
sad thought but Ben Affleck now is being
rumored that he may be the next
celebrity politician did you also hear
he was going to be Batman that was a
minor thing you might have missed on
Twitter but jennifer garner his wife had
a little something to say about it right
now Ben feels like he can do more good
for people politically from outside the
system would I be surprised if one day
he did go into politics no all right
that's it's a somewhat innocuous but
there's the hint there and people have
talked about Matt Damon maybe and you
know we've had a long history of actors
going into politics which we'll get to
in just a sec but do you think this is
the future that you're going to have to
be famous first to go into politics
Ronnie did it Ronnie pulled it off while
he did and I feel like we've been
hearing this about the bath the first so
long yeah he may be going in no he's not
going in no he's but he's so interested
in he might and yes he will probably get
elected to anything that he wants cuz he
I like him he's pretty and he's so smart
guy you know wouldn't be the worst
in the world but yeah it's it's a little
maybe can marry Batman and the
presidential campaign who can Batman can
you go directly from Batman to the
Senate that's the question yeah I mean
yeah you can do anything forget the
money got the right guys behind you pick
the right state sure you could do it
he's a very smart guy I don't know
whether he's you know I don't know
whether he's interested what they forget
is that you can be a smart guy to be
interested in the legislative process uh
which is you know can is dull unless
you're into it which case it's the
coolest thing you've ever been a part of
yeah something guys who were in it have
to be dedicated all these guys we bring
in now or guys who literally come in
they hate the process I hate designing
law and they think that that's their
jobs to come there and prevent laws and
growth and progress from happening I
mean if I don't say that they really
don't we know that's what they made yet
but do you think that's one of the
things with Obama that he really likes
campaigning and fundraising and speaking
but he's I've heard that he's not big on
the actual legislating and getting in
there and you know really working
through the bills with Congress and
what's up as opposed to someone I
Clinton who love that stuff love
striking a deal and all the new aisles
that well think would have gotten one
other thing done that brock obama has I
mean I really think that the obstinance
of the Republicans is such that would
matter II mean I don't maybe a little
and that may be true about Obama but he
is uh you know he's clear the kind of
leader who'd like to sort of shape out
the the the broad parameters and then
let his guys go to work but there's no
there's no going to work in the house it
can't be done guys aren't playing nicely
all right let's take a look at some of
the other actors who've gone into
politics this is just a tiny tiny list
Al Franken comedian he's now the senator
from Minnesota obviously Arnold
Schwarzenegger I still can't believe it
he was the governor of this state is
wild Ben Stein who you know he was in
win Ben Stein's money and he stuns and
Ferris Bueller's Day Off and all that he
was a speech writer for Nixon and Ford a
lot of people don't know that Clint
Eastwood was the mayor of Carmel
California Jerry Springer was a mayor of
cincinnati until he paid a hooker with a
check that's true Ronald Reagan
obviously was the governor of california
and
the president united states and Sonny
Bono with the mayor of Palm Springs
California this is just a tiny tiny unit
one that's really interesting that is
not on that list is a guy named a George
Murphy who beat uh JFK's press secretary
Pierre Salinger in California for the
senate race in 1964 George Murphy was
president Screen Actors Guild from
nineteen forty four forty six Reagan was
his deputy and George Murphy was a
big-time actor song and dance man first
and then became a kind of a b-movie
actor and a pretty good one and then
went to the Senate two years before
reagan went to the governorship he was
he's good-looking dude and he was very
reserved reagan before reagan and then
he went 64 insert l7ii and then and then
reagan came in 66 and went on to do a
couple laptop yeah they go hello I knew
there was a reason you know I want to
make sure I got and I want to make sure
I got a year right on George Murphy
finally someone fact-checking things we
do around here that's very nice um so
one of the things I brought up a couple
of times since we've been doing this is
that I partly think that what we need in
America is not that we need a monarchy
or a royal family but I feel like the
British somehow get out some of the
juiciness of politics with the royal
family and we want our politicians to be
everything we want them to be cool rock
stars like Obama and also nerdy policy
wants I don't know if that's possible so
is having celebrities be politicians is
that you just make the system that much
more maybe we should just select Ben
Affleck king prince but seriously it
does it gets out a lot of because we won
human can't be all those things and if
they are the perfect rock star the most
attractive person or the most
charismatic person they're not
necessarily gonna be the best
legislatively and if somebody's an
amazing you know legislature they're not
necessarily gonna be the most
charismatic Al Gore yeah um so what I
mean I it's it's a human thing though we
want people that we recognize and we we
feel attached to already it's so much
easier to we want them to make decisions
for us if they're on our ballot will
vote for them yeah I think it's a bad
thing like but it's the i think you're
right i don't think is any going back
from and then you hope that when we make
the mistakes that will make that those
guys proved to be different but the idea
ben affleck is eager and ready to work
with a 99 other guys on staying up roll
up the sleeves late at night with staff
to work out the intricacies of certain
legislation stand up to corporate
interest because there's nobody standing
up there in a general way for you know
regular people for working Americans
that they don't have a lobby alone poor
Americans I don't see that happening and
that's not indict that's not indictment
him I would want to do it right on also
the idea that he would immediately it's
obvious that if someone of Ben Affleck
snatcher and cloud was to run but
obviously you immediately run for Senate
he's not going to go be like a
congressional aide first or illusion
really in the house yeah yeah you got
that not someone like ya bish mouse the
house this mouse um what do you guys
think so Reagan is really the best
example of this though because he became
president now everyone thinks he's some
sort of God or at least half the people
do or something like that do the
Republicans have no chance to ever have
a famous person make it anymore because
it's all the celebrities now our
Democrats or I think there's a lot that
are actually closet Republicans yeah you
are there any who are the big
Republicans now better no better carry
Oldman he's British uh auntie Carmen uh
right Angie Harmon right Angie Harmon
there's what's his name from the dating
game Chuck Woolery the big retailer is
right yeah and I don't envy them yeah
Yahoo you literally get sick of being in
Congress in two minutes doing yeah James
Woods is another one either you guys
following him on Twitter he has become a
major right-wing yeah Haley yeah it's
funny James Woods is a fan of my father
through politics like through the 72
McGovern campaign so he's one of those
guys who had a transformation I guess I
didn't know that about James would ya
the other thing you hear about James
Woods hey I know about that bigger yeah
yeah he's well good google it you'll
figure it out that's our co-star yes
that's right yeah why though Jimmy woods
that's right i should mention by the way
this is the first time on the reuben
report that we have two people who
starred in one movie that's right Ben
and Jackie were both in white house down
did not have a scene together from
and I didn't have seen with anyone yeah
the other was another human it was funny
because I don't you guys the out of the
professional actors wrap that movie and
then we came in like eight weeks later
and not long before release that's right
in like march yeah where they work I
guess in some screenings they were like
a house the outside world know what's
happening here we have to we need well
really need the inside world to know
what's happening outside so we gotta
have some TV stuff and that was clearly
added later yeah I and God bless him and
I was excited to see thank you yeah I
had far more lives but for more lines
than I've had in anything ever said and
you killed it i totaled it right well
let's the perp that you give me a
perfect segue there let's keep talking
about movies so netflix has become
absolutely huge and there's article
after article about how their
revolutionising television and with
serious like house of cards and orange
is the new black and everyone is binge
watching now which is where you can
watch an entire series in three days
instead of watching it every Sunday
night on HBO and that this is the future
of television and I thought having you
two on it would be an interesting
discussion to talk about the movie
industry and is this the way that
everything's gonna go are I'm watching
all this netflix stuff and I do it in
the in the binge fashion um but is this
where movies are gonna go cuz that seems
to be the next logical step they're
obviously making a lot of money with
this they're getting huge buzz and it's
what people want right in their home are
we gonna be all watching movies on
Netflix you know made for netflix movies
take this one not that and that you're
the true pro on this Apple I mean it's
just a guess but no because the
movie-going experience that you know
started a little nickelodeon's and then
through silent felt like that's still a
thing and and people going out leaving
their homes and going to an event
together with other people and you know
go to dinner whatever get no hooker
whatever you do yeah that's still gonna
be an upright movie
yeah that was I think T yeah yeah the uh
uh uh so you know that that that that
will continue but what we are seeing is
this starting with the sopranos 1998
this incredible television renaissance
where I'm sure you recognize us as an
actress that the best writing there's
magic in Telluride Film Festival there
were some ice awesome great great movie
alexander payne's nebraska sensational
there's some great films but the best
writing is on television and it just is
and and and that you know I the show
that's on after breaking bad is show
called low Rising Sun with a wonderful
actor named Mark Strong about Detroit
homicide cops and as TV shows go it's I
don't know it's good it's not great you
know for my initial read obscene to
upset I like it i'll continue watching
it it is until i want to tell you right
it was better than the last eight movies
I'd seen just that it's shot better it
looks better the characters are
believable they're credible the
identifiable and it's not is not a great
show but it's ten times better than than
most movies and most big budget and I'm
guessing it didn't have a transformers
250 million dollar but which actually
probably a four hundred how do you feel
that as an actress that that the good
stuff the good writing and what would
give you the most sort of rewarding
experience as an artist is is the
television so amazing stuff i've just
read recently like something for amazon
i called transparent was so fantastic
just done amazon's doing the michael
connelly books Harry Bosch books that
are so great and that's you know and I'm
at and that those have been talked about
for a movie for years it we know fans
will always debate who should play the
lead character the detective in the la
Hollywood bureau and now that notion
that it's going to be on amazon it's
gonna be maybe ten episodes and you can
develop a month sounds sounds thrilling
I think the creators are at getting a
lot more control I you know I think
they're they're able to do a lot more of
what they want i would assume i don't
know this is but i would assume they're
they've just got more free reign to be
creative people and when you've got ten
episodes and you're not terrified you're
going to be pulled after episode 2 when
the ratings weren't there was an orange
as the new black was renewed before see
someone is fortune yeah because it's
going on you know what's actually good
which I feel like used
be what you know the more mainstream
look at yet we mentioned James Woods and
and James Woods and Jon Voight and liev
schreiber these are movie star yeah
these guys are doing ray Donovan on
Showtime and it's fantastic and they're
all three great in it and you know Tim
Olyphant was on the verge of being a
giant sewage I movie star he's like so
good looking at third straight guys
wanna and and he did and he's on he's on
FX are justified and Patton Oswalt kills
me that kevin's bay right i mean these
are serious actors there's anti shame
and going on television now there's a
Glenn Close so we're talking about my
sunglasses before and on damages that is
it's hardly shame it's uh it's it's a
blessing is now it so there's a little
cash a to it James become like ABC or
something like that isn't that crazy I
while I wouldn't do an ABC show oh yeah
we shall pay what do you guys think we
lose something by the binge-watching
experience because I said I do think
there's something to be said for the
fact that when Game of Thrones was on we
all saw the red wedding at the exact
same time and then everyone could
immediately jump on Twitter and go crazy
about it we're now if you watch this in
three days someone takes two weeks that
you do some of the shared experience
right becomes a race like although my
god you did it in four hours somehow you
watch 10 hours of television I can't
keep up with and I'm about to say this
but your life changes when you have
children and so less binge-watching so I
get like so I I don't think it's gonna
go away and I think it will still you
know the game of thrones' suddenly you
know and future seasons gonna get
released all at once I think this is an
alternative way that will change things
somewhat but I think it's also like it
did why are we you know we've so many
arbitrary things that we do things TV
shows come on once a week as we decided
they don't want the way that we say you
know uh the list of the 10 best of the
five s like what's wrong with eight and
what would be wrong with release in a
show mondays and thursdays record six
weeks like at some point some will try
something different as a as a movie
critic we know that we're told like the
late summer here in August is where they
put the summer movies they were you know
now to cover the put summer movies there
are expected to do well why like people
don't want to go in August like they
were in July but I never go to a movie
in artist and january-february where
movies get thrown because why like us
but why we never want to go to have a
good time on wednesday in january like I
i think a movie if it were good I just
think there's hate we think formulaic
Lee in this country and and maybe
that'll change to which would be
interested you can see a show twice a
week and make which trying to
revolutionize the way we think not just
about movies but many many things all
right one more we haven't talked about
porn I can't believe it we're gonna do
it right now speaking of things that we
watch a lot of porn hub which apparently
is a website i have no idea about that
they released extensive data about porn
watching habits and the geographic
locations of where people are watching
and what they're watching let's look at
this fancy map okay so many of you guys
are gonna have to pause this and really
take it in because there's a lot there
let's let's really leave this up now i'm
going to give you another image in a
second that's going to show you the
state by state but just look at some of
that so in new york they're going for
the college porn florida and many of
these other states in the south you're
getting [ __ ] google yeah so i had to
google it to Ben do you know what do you
know what google did not have i've got
all the yeah but I was like pies maybe
they're using cream pie yummy yeah so
I'm not going to explain all right we
can get off that map for a second I I'm
not gonna believe what just go back to
that I mean out what I just see
screaming at me isn't I Texas Oh Texas
Texas okay so we're gonna get all right
so let's jump to let's jump to the next
image here and this is the state
breakdown so Montana and Oklahoma they
love the but it's anal they all of it
Kentucky and Virginia love hentai yeah
do you want to explain what hentai is
all I could come up with from the
wikipedia was that it's it's crazy
japanese porn to make it crazy yeah
japanese animation inclination one yeah
anime anime okay let's go back West
Virginia loves large ladies that's BBW
for those keeping
home the west coast is really into agent
W big black woman was a big but big but
like women these black women computer
you please laughs yep and you've got the
laptop there by Ben Ben's gonna work on
that Wyoming and Idaho had some strange
strange fetishes including smoking
cigarettes and back room casting couch
so I I mean this is really fascinating
that depending on where you live in
these United States of America that your
porn habits are different uh do you guys
read into anything beautiful 10 big
beautiful women so that could be big
black women it could be big but in women
and I mean you could have the b.b.b.w
also as you I i think it was interesting
on that map that uh we see for one more
time it's really unimaginative if what
you like best is complete that's a
little of every that's like a little
it's a little it's a lot of one thing
really like if you're like yeah I want
to see I here's how much I don't know
ido not want a story I can't even sit
through two minutes in right right just
I just want the ending yeah yeah we just
want the [ __ ] shot anyone over and over
prepaid or it's a exact you just well
those no probably not probably not those
not uh but it's like it's like you just
want to turn on citizen kane and just
say no to sweat dr. Sledd fantastica and
then wanna see that's led over and over
and over yeah uh do you think there's
anything we can learn about this though
from some of the geographic stuff i mean
even in the south they see so there's
the team thing in texas and they they do
seem to like black porn more in the
house is that usually black populations
also so interesting i was thinking i was
actually thinking about it the other way
that because there's more racial tension
somehow in the South that it's white
people that are secretly while the
messed-up thing about calling it ebony
is assuming first of all what what what
is 2013 uh color for life is rejected
that um what black people can engage in
all the pornographic activities for
white people get you can actually you
can actually have a black copulation you
have your black [ __ ] your
black teens uh-uh you're black Asians uh
so yet but but i'm getting so they've
sort of made black one category which so
i'm gonna guess that's a that's gonna
tilt it slightly to states like South
Carolina which of forty percent black
populations they did I think that uh but
that's it I'm sure that you know there's
plenty of you know plenty of guys
harboring either out front or
deep-seated racial animus who are going
home and then watching black for not
only disgusting miles away where it
turns out a black people have sex
exactly the way white people why yeah no
we're done it laptop you're telling me
that blacks is as boring and stiff and
pathetic totally yeah um wow I totally
lost my thought on that I had pictured
there were so many things that I that I
picture there what do you think that
discuss one of the reasons I do these
segments every couple weeks on here is
that I do think porn has become so
mainstream but I actually think there's
something cathartic about talking about
it because everyone's at home watching
this on their computer and this is still
something that's done so privately and
yet everyone's doing it I think it's
important to talk about is that crazy I
love porn that way the camera what kind
of actress are you Jackie porn actress
but really do you think it's important
at some level to talk about something
that was never all about I'm always a
huge fan of talking about embarrassing
things because what humans are horrible
embarrassing weird little people inside
and we need to talk about it and share
our feelings to yourself uh I uh at what
you know it's a very big danger in life
it's what Republicans do is they they
extrapolate their own experience to
others like if I made it you could make
it right it's horse [ __ ] [ __ ] you um but
I'm about to do it diab please I wonder
whether we're getting close to a moment
of sort of demystifying porn for lack of
a better term certainly be demonizing is
probably better because there was a time
when if i watch something i would
instantly erase my history right right
and now i don't really care make like
also did you go on this computer you're
like a look what that was watching you
know I'd be like yeah whatever that's
right I don't plus you know the NSA is
watching anything
what does it make so you know i mean the
stigma is definitely at least for me
personally maybe that's just what you
reach your 7000 video you know like
you're not even excited but I'm gonna do
it yeah I'm all right what I do it so I
don't know I suspect we're getting close
to a point where we're certainly the
shame is removed at least a little
alright well there you go we've removed
the shame from porn hopefully we still
have a little shame related to war in
this country but unfortunately I don't
think so I want to thank Jackie Gary and
Ben mankiewicz o sub scribe every week
they tell me subscribe it's right down
there you click it it's simple I won't
bother just give me money when the on
the from the dvds of Noah of a white
house down Oh talk about that off the
air hey it's got to be coming out soon
you should does line watch white house
down when we can see these two alright
thanks for watching guys will do it
again next week